Florida Surgeon General Joseph ladapo
confirmed on Saturday what all
reasonable people have long suspected
namely that the MRNA covid vaccines are
associated with heart problems and death
especially in young people here's what
Surgeon General ledapo wrote
says that the Florida Department of
Health conducted an analysis through a
self-controlled case series which is a
technique originally developed to
evaluate vaccine safety this analysis
found that there is an 84 percent
increase in the relative incidence of
cardiac related death among males 18 39
years old within 28 days following mRNA
vaccination with a high level of global
immunity to covid-19 the benefit of
vaccination is likely outweighed by this
abnormally high risk of cardiac related
death among men in this age group and
and even further non-mrna vaccines were
not found to have these increased risk
which is why as such the state Surgeon
General recommends against males aged 18
to 39 from receiving mRNA covid-19
vaccines those with pre-existing cardiac
conditions such as myocarditis and
pericarditis should take particular
caution when making this decision
very scary stuff so naturally the big
Tech platforms censored him for
spreading medical misinformation and
undermining the public health and
authorities
which of course is a little bit strange
since Dr ladapo is one of the top
medical experts in the country and one
of the top Public Health authorities in
the country
the claim the idea that some random Punk
Twitter staffer possesses greater
medical expertise than the Florida
Surgeon General is insane and apparently
it was too much even for Twitter which
is why they eventually caved to
political pressure and restored Surgeon
General adapa's findings
but enough about the left's hypocrisy
yes they're power mad tyrants yes they
don't give a damn about the truth or
Justice yeah totally of course what is
more interesting to me than the double
standard here the the hypocrisy The
Hiding information what's more
interesting is the information itself
ladapa's findings
what should we conclude from the surgeon
general's finding that the MRNA vaccines
are associated with young people having
heart problems and dying
we should remember
that that conclusion now backed up by
one of those sacred studies on which
modern people place so much importance
that was not so long ago written off as
a crazy conspiracy theory not just by
the libs but by many squishes on the
right too the warning signs have been
there from the very beginning of these
vaccines do you remember that video of
the nurse who was taking the shot and
then she immediately fainted like right
away after taking it and the lib said oh
no it's no this is just coincidence no
big deal and then all of the anecdotal
reports of people having heart problems
that popped up just as the vaccines were
being rolled out all those many many
anecdotes the plural of anecdote by the
way is data all those warning signs were
ignored they were written off and the
people who kept talking about them we
were called conspiracy theorists well
the conspiracy theorists were right
100 right then just as the conspiracy
theorists have been right about so many
things in recent years which rages an
even more urgent question if the
so-called conspiracy theorists were
right about these things then
what sort of things are we mocking that
they are getting right right now I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on Friday is from Jessie Sanchez
who says just left a job after two days
because they tried to force me to use
pronouns screw that I have rights I will
not squish my girl that's great I assume
Jesse is a girl's name
it's I.E I think that's a girl's name
either way person person of unknown
pronouns good job good on you that is
great because to quote the the Butler
from the first season of the crown it's
in the little things that the rot begins
it's in the little concession say your
pronouns keep your mouth shut don't talk
about the vaccines on Twitter don't do
this don't come on just go along to get
along and and if once once you get
enough of that you lose all of your
integrity so good job great job not
squishing all right you clearly your
character is very very solid you know
what else is a solid valuable asset gold
that's why you got to check out Birch
gold right now text Knowles to 98 98 98
with the Consumer Price Index increasing
yet again the stock market has been an
absolute turmoil what is the
administration doing to quell The Surge
of inflation well spending more taxpayer
dollars of course do not bury your head
in the sand while your savings deplete
diversifying to gold with Birch gold
today 10 text Knowles to 98 98 98 and
Birch gold will send you a free info kit
on protecting your savings with gold in
a tax sheltered account the experts over
at Birch gold have almost 20 years of
experience in converting IRAs and 401ks
into precious metal IRAs gold has always
been your best hedge against inflation
a diversified savings can protect you
from downturns in the market if you've
got a 401k or IRA that is
underperforming just text Knowles kwels
to 98 98.98 you can convert that into an
IRA in Precious Metals right now Birch
gold group has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau countless
five-star reviews and thousands of
satisfied customers text Knowles kwles
to 98 9898 and Birch gold will send you
a free info kit on diversifying into
gold tax free take the necessary steps
to hedge against inflation today protect
your hard-earned money get your free
info kit by texting noltskin w l e s to
98 98 98 now
the issue here
is not do we trust the experts or do we
not trust the experts
okay the libs have been trying to frame
this whole debate going all the way back
to the start of covid as well either you
trust the experts or you don't trust the
experts and we Libs trust the experts
and you idiot conservatives don't trust
the experts and that's why you're dumb
and stupid and that's why we censor you
but that was never the game and this
proves it the Florida Surgeon General
thing proves it because that guy is an
expert that guy is a public health
authority he's one of the top Public
Health authorities in the country they
censored him anyway
because they were never on the side of
the experts writ large they were on the
side of their experts and their experts
are frequently idiots and always
perverted and incorrect they've got a
corrupted view of medicine and reality
that's how they keep getting everything
wrong
and conservatives
though we're distrustful of technocracy
and government by expert writ large
concern is we have our own experts we've
got plenty of very serious medical
doctors at very serious schools I'm just
thinking off the top of my head of of uh
Jay bhattacharya right at Stanford I
believe Dr Marty McCary
Dr Joseph ladapo here Dr Robert Malone
all of these people who are extremely
expert who have got very serious
credentials who have long histories in
their field and whenever those experts
contradicted the official narrative on
kovid what happened oh they're all
written off as cranks and fools and
idiots and never mind nothing to see
here just keep listening to to the real
experts like who like Joe Biden he's
some kind of Genius expert now
like like who Dr fauci a career
bureaucrat like who Rachelle valenski
like who Bill Nye the Science Guy
seriously they tried Bill Nye the
Science Guy out as their genius expert
so it's never about that okay it's
always about their narrative and their
conclusion and their their political
team
and then they're going to pretend that
that's the expert side but it's not and
and whenever an actual expert
contradicts their narrative they'll
censor him now in this case they there
was so much political pressure coming
especially from the state of Florida
they had to reinstate the post but they
don't like it they don't like it one bit
they only want their experts and their
experts are completely insane just look
no further than Boston Children's
Hospital Boston Children's Hospital not
only just put out an insane video on
transgenderism not only an incoherent
video on transgenderism but an
internally in a self-contradictory
incoherent video on transgenderism take
a listen
so most of the patients that we have in
the gems Clinic actually know their
gender usually around the age of puberty
but a good portion of children do know
as early as seemingly from the womb and
they will usually Express their gender
identity as very young children some as
soon as they can talk they might say
phrases such as I'm a girl or I'm a boy
or I'm going to be a woman or I'm going
to be a mom kids know very very early
children know that they're transgender
in the womb
children in the womb aren't children
they're just clumps of cells they're not
even human and they're not alive
those are two opinions that the libs
want us to hold simultaneously
what do you think the odds are that that
lady saying that supports abortion
a hundred fifty percent
I would bet I would bet a lot of money
that that lady's pro-abortion
I would bet my entire net worth that
the people who fall in line with her
argument broadly support abortion
and they support abortion because they
say usually the the mainstream
pro-abortion argument is oh it's not a
baby not human not alive not a person
when that suits there
argument on abortion but then when they
want to Peddle transgenderism they say
not only is it alive not only is it
human not only is it a person but it's
actually conscious and it's aware of
gender identity and the little blastula
or whatever stupid science jargony term
they want to use actually knows that
even though he looks like a boy he's
really a girl that's what and they want
you to believe that
that's what they
and when you raise any questions about
that they will brush you aside they'll
say oh you're not an expert you're an
idiot you don't know anything but it's
just arbitrary it's just capricious it's
it's the it's the exact same thing as Dr
fauci saying don't wear the masks and
then a week later wear the masks you
have to weigh The Masks what changed I
don't know shut up you stooge you little
sheep whatever I say I'm the science so
whatever I say is the truth it's just
it's the exact same thing and that's all
they ever say the the science worship is
just so preposterous
it's it's preposterous
in in the scientific terms that they're
using and it's Preposterous because
physical reality is not the Ultimate
Reality and we there's much more to talk
about
philosophy ethics theology all sorts of
things then just cells but even on the
level of science it's ridiculous Stacey
Abrams just proved this Stacey Abrams
got to give her some slight credit she
went on Fox News so she went on a
sometimes center-right News Channel and
was asked about her views on abortion
here's her answer
for you to become governor where would
you draw the line 15 weeks viability 36
weeks what's the limit
what I've always said is that abortion
is a medical decision that should be
made by a doctor and the woman and that
the point of viability as determined by
a doctor should always take into
consideration the life and health of a
woman that should be the standard but
the arbitrary standards of timelines
ignore the medical reality that it is a
fallacy we know exactly when a pregnancy
starts that we know exactly where we are
in the system I mean in the in the term
and what doctors will tell you is that
they need to make decisions based on the
woman they are treating and what women
will tell you is that they need the
right to make medical decisions that can
save their lives and save their ability
to control their bodies and their
Futures hold on hold on it's a fallacy
that we know when pregnancy starts
okay if you're telling me we maybe we
can't pinpoint the exact day or the
exact hour
maybe but I'm pretty sure by 36 weeks we
know the pregnancy has started right I'm
pretty sure after the mother's been
vomiting for about a month or two
morning sickness you know as her belly
grows for a lot I'm pretty sure we can
know the pregnancy has started right so
you can't draw the line there I don't
think that's just arbitrary or
capricious do you no she doesn't believe
that by the way we do know when a
pregnancy starts
starts at conception that's what the
word conception means so we know all of
that but what is what is Stacey Abrams
really saying here is she making a
scientific argument no she's making a
medical argument no is she making a
political argument
kind of she's it's not even much of an
argument it's she's just saying we will
do whatever I want to do we will do
whatever I want to do and we've come to
the conclusion and we'll backfill the
arguments and we'll backfill the reason
maybe then
but it it's ironic because Stacy Abrams
is apparently attacking arbitrary
politics and yet her Politics the
politics of the entire left is just
arbitrariness it's do whatever we want
now forget about the arguments that we
made yesterday I know we told you to
wear the mask yesterday I know we told
you the vaccines were totally safe
yesterday I know we told you to trust
the experts like the Surgeon General
yesterday yeah whatever forget about
that that was then this is now shut up
and do what I say that's that's their
political argument and when you want to
have a real reason discussions with your
friends and family you got to check out
pure talk right now go to puretalk.com
enter code Knowles the government is
addicted to spending that Reckless
spending is driving up costs on
everything it's not fair but you don't
have to just be a victim there are
things you can do right now to lower
your monthly expenses and mitigate the
impact of inflation step one this is the
simplest one switch your cell phone
service to Pure Talk take a look at your
cell phone bill if you're with Verizon
ATT or T-Mobile I know how much you pay
you pay too much pure talk will give you
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just thirty dollars a month that
could be a huge savings for you and your
family that's grocery money or gas money
and Pure Talk never raises their rates
by switching to Pure Talk the average
family of four is saving over 75 bucks
every month customers are realizing they
don't need as much data as they thought
okay join the hundreds of thousands who
are making the switch to pure talk today
when you switch to pure talk with our
special discount you will get 50 off
your first month go to puretalk.com
choose your plan enter code Knowles for
this special offer that's puretalk.com
enter code Knowles kwles for 50 off your
first month
the Democrats have made a little bit of
a mistake I think on abortion
they've realized that they've got
nothing going into the midterms not the
economy not immigration not National
Security not inflation not not anything
right they've got nothing going into the
election and so they've tried to focus
on abortion is there one issue because
the Supreme Court overruled Roe v Wade
and they think that'll energize
Democrats and the polling shows it
probably won't polling shows in as much
it does energize Democrats but it
actually seems to energize Republicans
as much or more and furthermore people
just don't vote on abortion Pro
pro-choice pro-life it's just not a top
priority for for the vast majority of
people maybe for you and me it is
because because if you're very pro-life
I certainly vote on the issue we're in
the minority of people
about 15 of people consider this to be a
real top priority so
Democrats have said okay might not be a
top priority but it's all we've got
going into November so we're really
going to focus on it and it's tripping
them up they don't know what to say
you've got Stacey Abrams saying well I
don't who really knows if you're
pregnant in 36 weeks I mean that's not
convincing anybody and then you've got
U.S rep Cory Bush who is a vocal
fanatical pro-abortion Defender going on
Margaret Hoover's PBS show and
describing an abortion Horror Story
I was thinking back to the first
abortion okay you've done this before
you know the rooms you know what it
looks like you know what it feels like
in in this place you know what to expect
you know
um that you may experience even some
harm or some racism in this in this
space
like I thought I was ready
because you had experiences previously I
had so I thought I was ready and I went
in and I went through all the steps
because they were like you it's almost
like an assembly line you know you go
from room to room and I got into the
last room I I was helped up onto the
table by the nurse and I laid there and
I started to think well one I didn't
tell the father that that was about to
happen
um I and I just I just felt like I
needed more time so I said no you know
what I'm not ready and the nurse just
you know wouldn't listen to me and I
said no I'm not ready and as I'm saying
no they continue to pull the instruments
and you know get everything ready and
and it was just like no calm down you
know no you're gonna be okay
and then they just killed her kid
without her consent
and so absolute Horror Story and I was
wondering I said how on Earth did Corey
Bush obviously this is horrifying
obviously this experience has bothered
her obviously it shows the horrors of
abortion
obviously she knows there's a problem
with abortion that's why she hesitated
because it's the little angel on one
shoulder and the little devil and the
other and the devil was saying kill your
kid Corey come on kill your kid again
and the Angel's saying don't do it Corey
this you know this is wrong don't do it
and the angel won out briefly and she
said no no I don't think I want to do
this and then this psychoabortion is
said too bad I'm killing your kid right
and and so she and I said how on Earth
did you even think to bring up this
story this obviously doesn't help her
political side and the only conclusion I
can come to is Corey Bush thought that
she could make a point about racism here
and she's spoken this way before where
she said because I'm a black woman my
opinions haven't been valued I haven't
been heard and so I think that was the
argument she thought that she was making
but really what she was doing was just
making a strong argument against
abortion so even if she's trying to
argue for it didn't didn't really work
very well and then that that's the first
thought and that's what most people have
been talking about but then there's the
second thought I had which is
she mentions that she'd already had an
abortion totally willingly and so she
went in she thought it was going to be
easy again she was gonna have a second
abortion and then she had some second
thoughts
I thought
we have a U.S representative a member of
Congress
casually discussing murdering her
children two of her children on
taxpayer-funded television
and pretty much everyone just shrugs it
off and says oh yeah that's normal
how insane is that
how insane is that in a sane Society I'm
not saying that parents would never kill
their children I'm not saying that there
would be zero abortions
but what I can promise you is that
if if parents did kill their children
they would keep it to themselves they
would be ashamed of that because it's
obviously very very wrong and they would
seek atonement and they would try to
repent and they would seek Absolution
for their sins and they would keep it to
themselves they wouldn't brag about it
casually
and you wouldn't have an interviewer
sort of nodding along oh yes you know
yeah that's right you killed your first
kid and then this happened and then oh
yeah and you wouldn't have a public just
saying okay this is totally normal for a
member of Congress
this is so scandalous our country is
such a
ah
not great place anymore I was going to
use that phrase that Donald Trump used
to refer to other third world countries
what a horrible country is it at this
moment that we just shrug this off how
far have we Fallen this used to be a
great country this used to be the
greatest country on Earth how far have
we Fallen that we just say oh yeah yeah
our public officials go on
taxpayer-funded television and just
casually discuss murdering their
children and everyone's just kind of
like cool with that and that's normal
that is so sick this woman should be
ashamed to show her face in public if
this is her point of view
and yet she's lauded and applauded she
has no compunction whatsoever
that is insane
absolutely how do we tolerate this we
should not tolerate this we should
conservatives need to embrace much more
of a cancel culture I'm not saying for
any woman who's had an abortion by the
way I know women who have had abortions
and multiple abortions some of whom are
unrepentant some of whom they can't get
it out of their head
and so the women should know you you can
repent you can your sins can be forgiven
you can move on but the key there is the
repentance right you've got to change
your mind you've got to recognize the
moral reality or else you can never move
on and there should be a society of
Grace and forgiveness and all of those
things and and we need much more of that
in society too but you can not not if
you're not if you're bragging about it
not if you're completely unrepentant
those people should be completely
ostracized those people should not be
permitted to show their face in society
they should not be given seats at
restaurants they should not be permitted
on television or in the Public Square
it's so horrif horrifying
and yet we just totally today the only
people we ostracize are the pro-lifers
then we said we send the doj to go
arrest the pro-lifers it's just
completely backwards
should not tolerate that speaking of a
restriction of Tolerance on a completely
separate subject but still the same Libs
The New York city mayor Eric Adams
he's had enough of Tolerance okay he
says we've tolerated these illegal
aliens way too long these the Texas
governor he's sending too many illegal
aliens to our city he hasn't even sent
that many by the way we're still talking
in the thousands we're not even getting
close to the hundreds of thousands or
Millions as you know we have two million
illegal aliens cross into our country
every single year we're talking about a
very small number of them
have been shipped to New York
and the New York city mayor says enough
is enough
New Yorkers are angry I am angry too
we have not asked for this there was
never any agreement to take on the job
of supporting thousands of Asylum
Seekers this responsibility was simply
handed to us without warning as buses
began showing up
there's no playbook for this no
precedent there's no no playlist we
didn't want these people we didn't
invite these people we didn't call our
city a sanctuary City for years and
years and years we didn't explicitly
invite these people I personally on
Twitter and on National Television oh
wait a minute
just over a year ago you tweeted quote
New York City will remain a sanctuary
city under an Adams Administration what
is your message to migrants arriving in
the U.S should they still come to New
York City well I think that they should
come to any place in the country that
they desire uh their pursuit of the
American dream
ooh oops remember that mayor Adams
never mind
never mind it's this it's the same thing
with the masks it's the same thing with
the Jabs it's the same thing with their
constantly changing and inverting
arguments on transgenderism and abortion
and never mind never mind it doesn't
matter what I said yesterday the
argument that I just made to you five
seconds ago that no longer matters if
it's no longer convenient for me because
the libs politics though they pretend
it's grounded on science and reason in
fact has absolutely nothing to do with
any of that it is merely their own
interest it that's baked into the
equation because the libs politics is a
view that denies the the real objective
moral order that denies any duty to
tradition or the community or to God
himself it just ignores all of that
stuff it is a politics of pure interest
whatever I want I will take it by any
means necessary and so of course they're
going to change their arguments the only
the only thing that we should get out of
this is not that we need to make fun of
them for being Hypocrites anymore yes of
course they're Hypocrites they don't
even they don't even really have a
standard so they can't even really be
Hypocrites because they don't actually
believe any of the things that they're
saying the only thing that we should
take out of this and conclude and
remember this every single time the libs
open their mouths is they're not making
arguments they're just doing whatever
the hell they want to do and we should
stop them from doing it and stop
pretending stop trying to engage in
their arguments they don't care about
that we care more about their stupid
arguments than they do they're going to
change them the very next day the moment
that it's convenient for them
speaking of insanity in New York
I wish I had the Nostradamus hat I don't
have it on me I got I gotta remember to
Move It from my office to my studio
because we just keep being right and
it's not just me
it's all of us it's all anyone who has
any inkling of any kind of social
conservatism anyone who's ever even
uttered the phrase slippery slope
in a sort of mocking way because where
every time we make a prediction we're
told well you know you're just making a
slippery slope argument yeah well the
slope is pretty freaking slippery man
and here's the latest one a New York
City judge has just ruled that
polyamorous unions are entitled to the
same rights as married couples
that was a conspiracy theory about 18
hours ago that was a crazy idiotic
conspiracy theory get out your tinfoil
hat you slippery slope lunatic you're
telling me just that just because we've
radically redefined the Bedrock social
institution that pretty soon we're going
to have
polygamy legalized
come on you nut that has nothing we just
want gay men to feel happier or
something whatever the argument was for
Love Is Love equal sign
it's all the same or what I don't even
whatever the dumb arguments everyone has
the right to get married and the
conservatives said at the time
well you know if you radically redefine
marriage in this way and you divorce it
from its tradition and its natural state
then there's going to be no limit to how
you can redefine it and pretty soon
we're going to have not just same sex
marriage but you're going to have
polygamy and marriages just effectively
going to be abolished
and then that's um
that's exactly what is happening exactly
what is happening what's this case it's
the Case Case of West 49th Street LLC
versus O'Neill and the New York Civil
Court Judge Karen May bakdayan
has reportedly concluded that
polyamorous relationships are entitled
to the same sort of legal protection as
two-person married relationships
because the case involves Scott Anderson
and Marcus Marcus O'Neill who lived
together in a New York City apartment as
well as Anderson's husband Robert Romano
who resided elsewhere but says that he's
in a in a throuple he's in a polyamorous
relationship with these two men and so
we we take one step and we say okay
we're going to pretend that this Union
of two men is is marriage since 2015
we're going to pretend that that's
marriage and but but we're not just
going to leave it there we can't just
leave it there because if we're going to
radically redefine marriage that much
what then why wouldn't we say look these
three men apparently do weird sex stuff
together regularly so why why would we
if
if marriage can be two guys why can't it
be three guys
why can't it be
explain to me because they're going to
be I know that there are some
conservatives who are on board with
redefining marriage or a burgerfel or
whatever okay then if you're on board
with that just explain to me why
the so-called right to same-sex marriage
doesn't
get to go this far as to include
polyamorous unions because I can't find
the argument for that
especially in New York City where
everyone was always trying to cheat the
different marriage laws in order to keep
their Apartments because the most
valuable thing in New York is not your
family or your loves or even a bar of
gold the most valuable thing in New York
is just keeping your apartment that's
any New Yorker knows this okay so why
would there not be not only why would
there not be an incentive for this sort
of thing why would this not take place
I personally know
what gay guys specifically who I I know
having lived in New York in Los Angeles
and lots of eccentric people I know
people who kind of have open marriages
or all that sort of stuff but
specifically gay guys I know who do this
sort of thing this is not just a a weird
margin tabloid thing that you read about
once this happens actually somewhat
regularly
so why can't they have the same legal
protections Love Is Love right
Love Is Love and apartments are very
valuable when are we going to say enough
when are we going to say enough the left
has no problem saying enough enough to
Christianity enough to the American
tradition enough to our way of life
enough to us having our money enough to
us raising our kids enough to us doing
anything really that we want to do and
that we actually have a right to do when
our conservatives going to say enough
ever no all conservatives well you know
you do whatever you want just don't take
my money oh you know just you guys I
have no problem if this throuple wants
to keep their New York City apartment
and pretend that it's marriage just
don't you know just don't tell me what
to do they're going to tell you what to
do they have to tell you what to do it
we live in society folks we live in a
political community and we have
self-government self-government means we
all tell each other what to do that's
that's what that that's essentially what
that is when are we going to say enough
I will impose my moral view on you just
like you're going to impose your immoral
view on me I am going to say no enough
I'm going to impose my actual moral view
on you that's going to give all of us a
much better life and stop leading this
country down to Hell in a hand basket we
know the country is getting worse on
virtually every statistic things are
getting worse the economy is insane we
have zero trust in Republic institutions
crime is going through the roof the life
expectancy is going down because people
are despairing and killing themselves
and overdosing on drugs the country is
getting worse on pretty much every
single metric why because of this
Insanity because and every single aspect
of public policy the libs are forcing
their insane perverted Vision on society
and the conservatives don't have the
guts or the spine or any other Anatomy
chemical features to say no enough is
enough I'm going to stop you from
imposing your view on society and we're
going to impose our view on society
because our view is better for everybody
are we ever going to do that I don't
know we're all we're like we're transd
the conservatives have gotten trans
we've we've got must have gone through
the surgery somewhere and lost the body
parts that give us the courage to do
that sort of thing our eyes first of all
all right get your head out of the
gutter but the other ones too we've lost
well we've got to get it back or we
might as well just hand the whole
country over to the libs gotta say
enough
I've got I've got the least shocking
story of the week for you you ready for
the least absolute you are gonna you're
not even gonna blink
a uh transgender tick tocker
a man you know who is severely mentally
ill and sexually perverted
he has just been arrested on eight
counts of child sex abuse this is the
guy
hello
here we are inside
[Music]
well we still haven't hit that ten
thousand Lots yet so I can't tell you a
bedtime story no I can't I told you ten
thousand then you get your bedtime story
but
I've been um
I've been thinking
what do you think of
Rachel
Queen Australia
[Music]
just a thought
[Music]
oh let me know what you think
it's always the ones you most expect you
know isn't it funny how that work it's
always the ones you most expect this man
who is obviously
not just deluded not just given to
Fantasy this man who's obviously
severely mentally ill not only
identifies as a woman and dresses up
like a woman like a bizarre caricature
of a woman but is now presenting himself
as Rachel the queen of Australia
this guy might have some weird sexual
Hang-Ups and act on them
would you ever you just I'm saying you
it's just me and you here you're not
you're not on camera okay you're not
gonna be fired from your job or kicked
out of school for saying this
would you ever let your kid go anywhere
near that guy
even you didn't hear the story you
forget about he's been arrested on it
child sex abuse
would you ever you see that guy in the
street would you ever let your kid go
near that guy of course not
because you would have a Prejudice that
that guy has got some weird sexual
problems and is probably poses some
threat some danger to your kid
it's just a Prejudice I'm not saying you
don't have a study you don't have
experts telling you that you just it's
just deep down in your gut
you you think that and all the experts
are going to tell you no no that guy
doesn't pose any threat to your kids no
no actually he poses the least threat to
your kids if anyone he's totally
sexually sane oh no that guy man he's
way saner than anybody and so it's it's
your gut versus the experts and your gut
is right
and your gut is right
remember remember on the covid vaccines
when all the experts said these are
totally safe totally effective they will
prevent you from getting covered they
will prevent you from transmitting covid
there's no health risk whatsoever
and then your gut said I bet that's not
true
I bet your gut said I bet this won't
stop me from getting it I bet this won't
stop me from transmitting it and I bet
it does pose health risks
your gut was right on every count
the experts were wrong on every count
sorry I shouldn't say all the experts
the experts that the libs exalt
were right on every single count which
brings me to Jon Stewart Jon Stewart
just went viral in a clip that I think
makes him look like a complete hack in
buffoon but the clip has gone viral on
the on the left as an example of of Jon
Stewart totally owning the Republican
Arkansas attorney general with facts and
Logic on this very point take a listen
why would the state of Arkansas step in
to override
parents Physicians
psychiatrists
endocrinologists who have developed
guidelines why would you override those
guidelines
well I think it's important that all of
those Physicians all of those experts
for every single one of them there's an
expert that says we don't need to allow
children to be able to take those
medications that there are many
incidences where but you know that's not
true you know it's not for everyone
there's one there's these are the
established well I don't know that
that's not true I don't know that then
why would you why would you pass a law
then if you don't if you don't know that
that's true wouldn't you well I know
that there are doctors let me let me try
and flip it a different way and see if
maybe this this can help in Arkansas if
you have pediatric cancer
and obviously we all want to protect
children I think we established that
earlier
whose guidelines do you follow for
Pediatric cancer
whose guidelines do you follow this is
his own you follow the doctors
so then if you follow the doctors on a
very long-standing well-established body
of medical literature on how to treat a
very specific ailment that will kill
your child then why don't you trust them
when they want to cut your child's penis
off
um do I do I even have to answer that
question by the way the very fact that
the so-called medical experts are now
advocating pumping little kids full of
cross-sex hormones and trying to
mutilate them into being the opposite
sex actually does make me less likely to
trust them on the cancer treatment and
on every other aspect of Medical Science
but do you see what Jon Stewart is
advocating here he's advocating a
complete blind allegiance to and faith
in the political establishment
not even just the medical experts
because as the Arkansas attorney general
rightly points out there are many
experts on the other side and Jon
Stewart doesn't even really quibble with
that he says well it's not one to one
there's not one of your experts for
every one of our experts which may or
may not be true sort of who cares he's
at least conceding the premise that yes
you conservatives the people who oppose
chopping off little kids genitals you
guys have some experts on your side but
we have other experts and anyway our
experts are the ones that are enshrined
in the political establishments you
should trust them a complete Blind Faith
ironic of course because Jon Stewart
presents himself as speaking truth to
power and the whole left presents itself
as being sort of counter-cultural and
fighting the entrenched Powers when in
fact they they are the only entrenched
power in the country
but imagine that
imagine imagine thinking that let's just
say Jon Stewart's being sincere for a
second
he is he is actually telling people not
to believe their own eyes not to use
their own brains not to use their own
reason not to not to trust anything that
happened before yesterday before today
why wouldn't you trust the experts I I
wouldn't trust the experts because they
are saying that boys can actually be
girls
that's why that's the proof that they're
not omniscient not necessarily correct
here not the Geniuses you're presenting
them to be the very fact that they're
saying that
is the proof that they are not
that they are not these people and John
Stewart actually makes a joke earlier in
this clip he says you know some people
used to make jokes about transgenderism
but those guys were totally wrong and
then he plays a clip of himself doing it
on his show but he says but now I've
been told by the political establishment
that's not true so I'm going to ignore
even what I used to think but just look
at the record here
the Prejudice of the people the wisdom
of repugnance of Ordinary People the
intuitions and natural inklings of
Ordinary People
in recent years has been proven much
much more reliable much much more
correct much much more trustworthy than
the fantasies and pronouncements of the
exalted established experts
you know today is Columbus Day
530 years ago great man named
Christopher Columbus discovered the new
world
1492 Christopher Columbus one of the
great men of history sailed the ocean
blue and then the libs ruined the new
world so Jeremy's building a new new
world that's right starting with his
razors right now you can get your
Jeremy's razors founder shave kit for 40
off plus free shipping as part of an
historic Columbus Day sale
the libs want to erase history and
masculinity you do not have to let them
do it navigate your way to
jeremy'sraisers.com to conquer your
stubble and arrive in style this holiday
speaking of the political establishment
PayPal is just announced
that they will now steal your money for
wrong think
for contradicting political correctness
for expressing any kind of opinion that
does not go along with the opinions of
the experts and the opinions but of the
established experts by the way change
every day so you better be careful with
what you say
the PayPal released new user terms
it's new acceptable use policy in which
it said that it would that you can't use
PayPal services for activities that
relate to transactions involving drugs
okay that's fine
they relate to stolen goods yeah that
makes sense that relate to the promotion
of hate violence racial or other forms
of intolerance that is discriminatory
okay now that's a little confusing yeah
violence I get
but what how are they defining hate and
what are you saying you're saying you
discriminated against what you're saying
just intolerance what is that that seems
a little that seems a little dodgy
obscenity that seems fine to me
sexually oriented materials that seems
fine to me Firearms that's dumb but okay
whatever I guess it's their company
okay
they say that they may liquidate damages
of 2500 2500 U.S per violation which can
be debited straight from your PayPal
account they go on to say further that
they can just take money out of your
account they can freeze your assets they
can take your money if you
do things that they don't like
things that are not necessarily illegal
things that have not necessarily even
been considered bad
in in American history what if you're
transphobic
quote unquote
but if you're homophobic what if you're
what if you don't what if you don't post
the black BLM flag
the black Square on social media what
happens then
this is not just some crazy conspiracy
theory the former president of PayPal
has confirmed this and criticized it he
said
it's hard for me to openly criticize a
company that I used to love and gave so
much to but PayPal's new AUP acceptable
use policy goes against everything I
believe in a private company now gets to
decide to take your money
if you say something that they disagree
with Insanity then Elon Musk
another billionaire long connection to
paypalies has agreed totally agreed and
and the way you know that this was true
and not just fake news conspiracy theory
whatever is that PayPal reversed the
decision after daily wire published a
story criticizing it
gets back to those conspiracy what do
the conspiracy theorists say not that
long ago
they said that the United States while
we criticized China for its social
credit score system and its oppressive
tyrannical government that the U.S is
implementing the exact same thing and
it's doing it a little more subtly and
it does it under the Aegis of the
corporations and the non-government
organizations and the non-profits and
the semi-state public-private
partnership but it's the exact same
thing if you contradict the prevailing
social mores in any way or the slogans
of political correctness or wokeism
you're going to have your money taken
away you're going to be ostracized from
society it's the exact same thing the
exact same sort of system in China is
being implemented in the United States
there's no question is it at the same
scale yet no is it at the same point yet
no is it going to take the same exact
form no but the result will be largely
the same it's certain that's certainly
with the libs want
that is happening now
who know what if you say don't wear the
masks they could maybe they could take
your money
maybe you could say Dr fauci told me
that and then say no no Dr fauci said
that yesterday but today he's saying the
opposite so you have to say the opposite
now
what if it's
what if it's basically any other topic
children
babies in the womb aren't babies no no
today we're saying they are babies
because they can know that they're
transgender in the room sorry 2500 bucks
nope sorry I'm gonna take three thousand
this time
okay fine babies in the womb or babies
oh no today it's today we're advocating
for abortion so they're not babies
anymore but there's 2500 sorry gotta
keep up gotta keep up with the political
correctness guys otherwise we're gonna
take all your stuff and kick you out of
society
speaking of
taking money back there is some good
news I don't want to leave you on all
this Downer kind of news there is some
really good news Sharon Osbourne
has uh
decided that BLM is in fact a scam
as Kanye West declared the other day BLM
is a scam and she wants her money back
agree with Kanye's point
I don't know what his point is I mean he
said that black lives matter is the scam
oh well we gave nine hundred thousand
dollars to that and
um I'd like my money Bank yeah yeah well
she could have said that before
[Laughter]
wow an amazing statement there
there's so much there's so much in that
statement because what Sharon Osborne is
saying is yeah couldn't really admit
this before but I want my money back so
she's actually saying that Kanye and
Candace did kill black lives matter as
they said that they did and Candace has
a new movie on this coming out that is I
think gonna put the final nail in that
coffin it's coming out uh just this week
I believe it's going to be absolutely
fabulous
so she's saying yeah that's true and I
have long known that this thing was a
scam but now I'm allowed to say it and I
want my 900 000 back because it was all
scam and we know that the leaders of it
basically just exploited George Floyd
who no one actually really cared about
none of the people who pretended to care
about him actually really cared about
him they just used him as a symbol to
raise a lot of money and buy big
mansions in California and yeah I want
my money back
that's what she's saying and and this
could be effective
Sharon Osborne is never going to get a
penny back but if you have all of a
sudden
prominent people coming in saying give
me my money back this is a scam I'm
going to throw my financial waiter in
she I suspect felt like she was being
extorted into giving money
I remember when BLM took over Southern
California you had businesses posting
receipts in their windows
of donations to the BLM organization
like like blood over their door frames
to say please please agents of death
pass by this house don't kill us you'd
have people saying this is a black owned
business in other words go kill whitey
don't don't go after Russia I don't and
the white people was I donated money
please again it's no different than the
mob except that the mob used to only
take 10 of your stuff and the libs come
in and they basically want everything
that's the difference
that's that's the big difference here
and now Sharon Osborne is admitting that
I think a lot of people feel that way
and if more people just get a little bit
of courage to say yeah no actually the
established narrative about BLM was
complete BS and we shouldn't have gone
along with it and I'm sorry we allowed
ourselves to be extorted that's that's
uh fine that's fine you know where you
really see this is a completely
different point
but I have to get to it today
horrible terribly sad story two children
were killed and a mother was critically
injured after the family's dogs attacked
now before I tell you what kind of dog
it was
you already know right was it a DOT was
it was it a wiener dog
was it a pug
was it a golden retriever
no
you know it was a pit bull because it's
always a pit bull because the majority
of the time when a dog mauls somebody or
eats a poor little kid it's a pit bull
we know this because the pit bulls were
bred to do this that's what they're for
and yeah we are told by the experts of
our society no no that's not true it's
no there's no such thing as a bad breed
of dog well maybe not good or bad but
it's just the breed was bred to to be
extremely violent and and so now we have
them and we have them around
two-year-old little kids that's why
these stories keep happening no no not
my dog there's no such thing as a bad
dog breed just bad owners no they just
didn't love their dog the right way oh
that's weird a lot of people just not
loving their pit bulls the right way and
for some reason the people the bad dog
owners they always seem to own pit bulls
and it's just coincidentally always the
pit bulls that are attacking people
and just coincidentally they're
genetically built for that
but that's just a weird coincidence
it's weird these pitbulls always at the
center of such coincidences
I know this is going to be controversial
I know some people like the dogs
we should obviously kill all the
pitbulls right it's not enough even to
sterilize them because the problem is
not that there will be more pit bulls in
the future the problem is the pit bulls
are the dogs that attack everybody now
and threaten People's Kids now and lead
to these horrible stories and parents
say oh no the dogs were the dog was
never
violent before the dog lived with us for
years yeah and the dog was never violent
until he was and whenever the dogs are
violent it just usually most of the time
tends to be the pit bulls and we have no
reason to tolerate that we as a society
have a great reason to protect against
that
there is no there was no Second
Amendment right to a pit bull there is
no natural law reason to have a pit bull
we we have to admit reality
okay this is not and we have to admit
that all the all the experts in this
case on the dogs no no it's actually
just training and actually actually if
you look at this statistic and actually
if you no it's just not true we know we
know it we all know it okay even the
Pitbull owners know it okay stopped in
the ah stop denying things that you know
are true because some lib Egghead with
uh some kind of mellifluous argument
has convinced you not to trust your gut
in your head and history and everything
that we know is true okay stop trying to
make yourselves so gullible
this is true forget the pit bulls for a
second this is true on transgenderism
it's drawn abortion it's true on our
country's history it's strong crime it's
running immigration it's throwing all of
these things okay we know basic stuff we
have common sense we have eyes we can
see nature we see stuff all around us
okay we have at least two brain cells to
rub together we know that
and the purpose of leftist politics the
goal of leftist politics is to tell you
to ignore everything you know
and to convince yourself of their
fantasies
to convince yourself that Richard Levine
is actually a woman
it's okay to trust your prejudices it's
okay to trust received wisdom it's okay
to trust your faculties of Reason okay
they've got a much better record you're
going to be called a conspiracy theorist
for trusting all those things but
they've got a much better record than
the so-called experts today is music
Monday okay
we've got a a song
that was requested by one of the great
members of this show who we will see in
the member block and my producer Ben
Davies has teed it up for me he tells me
I'm going to hate the song but we'll see
the rest of the show begins now if you
don't want to miss it Well you certainly
don't want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us we will see you over at the
member block
[Music]
[Music]